شكرا حسن الى المفاوضات الجاريه الان في
نيروبي والتي تختتم هذه المفاوضات الجوله
الثانيه من اجتماعات ممثليه الحكومه
الاثيوبيه وجبهه الترايه بحضور ممثلي
الوساطه الافريقيه وبحثت هذه الجولات
ترتيبات الامنيه وسحاب القوات الاجنبيه
اضافه الى فتح ممرات بريه وجويه وضع خارطه
زمنيه لايصال المساعدات والسعاده الخدمات
في اقليم
الوسيط الافريقي لتوفير الاجواء المناسبه
لايقاف الاعمال العاديه
وتنفيذي وقفه اطلاق النار
ميدانيا وتحرير التراي ما اعلنت الحكومه
الاثيوبيه بشان سيطرتها على السبعينا في
المئه من اراضي
ووصول لمساعدات الانسانيه للاقليم وكان
مستشار رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي للامن
القومي رضوان حسين اكد سيطره اثيوبيا على
هذه المناطق وقلين هذه المساعدات تتدفق
على المناطق التي تسيطر عليها اديس ابابا
وان الحكومه سمحات بالرحلات الجويه لايصال
المساعدات للاقليم بموجب اتفاقيه السلام
المدرسه بابا مدير مكتب الجزيره محمد طه
توكل محمد طه كيف يمكن تفسير هذا التباين
في المواقف بين الحكومه وجبه تحرير تيجراي
بعد توقيع اتفاقيه السلام وفي خدمه
مفاوضات جاريه حاليا في نيروبي
حير الناس
بعد ان ساد التفاؤل بين كافه الاطراف وهنا
كان الترحيبات
هنا في اديس ابابا وفي الاقاليم الاثيوبيه
الاخرى وايضا في اقليم تقراي كان ترحيب
بالاتفاق وكانت المطالبه بتنفيذ الاتفاقيه
هذه التصريحات المتباينه التي سدرت ربما
تكون هناك مؤشرات لتعاصر المفاوضات وربما
تكون هناك حاله من التباينات بين الجانبين
هذا التسريحات المتباينه احدثت
حاله من
ردود فعل سلبيه في اوساط متباينه ولكن
المفاوضات وسيله هي شاقه ومعقد الجوله
الثانيه وهي مفودات يشارك فيها رئيس هيئه
الاركان القوات المسلحه الاثيوبيه والرئيس
المؤسسه العسكريه او قائد الجيش فبالتالي
الشقه الاخطر واكثر تعقيدا هو المفاوضات
الجاريه في نيروبي هناك ترتيبات امنيه همم
كما هو معلوم وسيله اكثر من همم 150 الى
250,000 مسلح من الجانبين كيف سيتم فصلهم
حسن الاتفاقيه قالت ينفذ عمليه الرحلات
الجويه المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان يستتب
الامن على الارض بدون ان تكون هناك
واضحه فبالتالي هناك تجاوبات هناك ايضا
همم ااه اتهامات متبادله من الطرفين وايضا
لا يوجد طرف محايد في مناطق المواجهات
فكثير من التعقيدات لا زالت قائمه همم كان
هناك تحويل كبير وسيله ان يتوسل العسكريين
الى اتفاقيات بالامس نقل التلفزيون لسبب
الرسمي بعد المحافظات الاثيوبيه همم في
اقليم استطلاع سكان المواطنين وايضا في
اقليم عفر واهم حره الكل يرحب بالسلام
والذي قال انتظاره ويتوقع ان تحدثه خاصه
اجت تصريحات مع انتهاء المفاوضات المتوقعه
مساء اليوم في نيروبي وسيله شكرا جزيلا لك
محمد طه توكل مدير مكتبنا في اديس ابا